leute bleibt unbedingt bis zum ende dran
am ende verkündete ich ein produkt was
es so in deutschland noch nie gegeben
hat
schild es hat alles seine gründe
red mick slater zürich wurde heute bei
enorm vielen instagram bildern gezeigt
dass der luca job down sei und mir aber
dass auch viele leute per mail
geschrieben und herr
twitter-mitteilungen irgendwie an michel
platini sind halt in den shop gegangen
haben das hier gesehen weitere zwei
stunden 28 minuten und vier sekunden ich
dachte halt dass keine fragen aufkommen
wenn ich darunter einfach einen text
schreibe und zwar der luca steht in
kürze wieder verfügbar sein so zeit
wollen wir den schon ein wenig um so
dass er noch schöner wir in der zeit bis
der countdown abläuft haben wir hier ein
paar vorschläge zum zeitvertreib für
euch pizza essen pizza essen pizza essen
liebe grüße luca der job es also nicht
irgendwie runter genommen worden weil
ich gehackt wurde oder weil der shop
gehackt wurde oder weil das eben videos
wurde und irgendwie alles offline jetzt
genommen wurde weil dazu viele keine
ahnung sondern wir haben das wirklich
gemacht weil ich mir gedacht habe jo am
ersten zwölf kommen zu der krasseste
lounge den ich je irgendwie erlebt haben
irgendein youtuber online shop in
deutschland ich wollte dann einfach 50
stunden vorher den job wirklich down
nehmen so dass die leute sehen ob hey
ich kann fliegt bestellen erst wieder am
ersten zwölfter um 16 uhr mez
zwischenzeit nehmen wir jetzt quasi
änderungen am shop vor das heißt wir
verändern das layout so ein bisschen wir
haben schon neue bilder gemacht die zeit
ich hörte
am ende des videos also bleibt dran wenn
ihr sehen wollt was wirklich dann
übermorgen alles neuen länder schon
kommt die macher neue
produktbeschreibung wir haben neue
banner aufgenommen cetera pp natürlich
kann man solche ganzen änderungen auch
so machen dass sie quasi ist der shop
online bleibt bis zum ersten 12 15 und
59 und dann springt es quasi um habe ich
schon irgendwie cooler wenn die
sinntaler beziehungsweise dem countdown
weil ihr seid war sich auf der website
drauf und die ganze zeit zählt dieser
website einfach unter wann der erste
zwölfter um 16 uhr stattfindet oder
panik vor sich wieder was einkaufen
könnte der shop wieder verfügbar ist
aber jetzt zu der sache wonach mich
circa alle von euch in den letzten tagen
und wochen darauf angesprochen haben was
sind eigentlich die neuen produkte ich
fange erst mit dem beutel an und zwar
habe ich den ja schon mal bei snap chat
gezeigt es ist gerade stockfinster
meiner wohnung und hier ist der neue
beutel
der smiley auf dem beutel leuchtet
einfach im dunkeln beim wollte habe ich
mir einfach gedacht der bisherige ich
hunger kurzem bisherigen beute das hier
ist der bisherige beutelt bin ich auf
jeden fall ultra kuhl von der farbe
haben wir ein eher schlicht gehalten und
einfach dann in schwarze smiley drauf
aber ich habe mir gedacht ich hab den so
oft genutzt die firma ist ein bisschen
griffiger etwas einfach noch geiler als
und dann war ich eines tages in dem club
bootshaus in köln und habe dort diesen
beutel entdeckt und die beute sieht
quasi schon recht ähnlich aus nur der
hut sondern richtig feste materialien
das merkt man den zu macht der ist
richtig fest oben er ist einfach viel
krasser allein hier vor den ganzen
knoten drin und was alles jetzt einfach
hält dich übels geil
bei den leuten von meinem shop
nachgefragt so können wir so was
vielleicht auch machen aber doch ein
bisschen cooler uns war quasi machen
genau diesem beutel in der berliner froh
dass auch hat allerdings kommt ein
weißer smiley drauf wer im dunkeln
leuchtet also ich habe es ja gerade
schon ein rezept für ein bett und
gezeigt ich euch eingeblendet habe aber
ihr könnt ihn euch quasi tagsüber
irgendwie ans fenster hängen oder ein
zimmer packen und wenn ihr danach nach
draußen läuft läuft dann ist das quasi
so wie mit diesen sternenbildern die man
früher bei kindern ihnen gern die decke
geklappt hat die dann für 20 30 minuten
geleistet haben und das ist ultra coole
nummer 2 was sie ab dem ersten 12 16 uhr
luca shop erwerben könnt ist dieses
dingen an meinem handy hinten dass teile
von pop socke das kann man einfach hin
an das handy dran kleben kann man es
quasi so ein klappen wenn man das handy
ganz normal nutzen will oder man kann es
auch komplett aus klappt dann kann man
das handy festhalten kann ist weil sie
so heilen kann besser zu machen wenn ihr
beispielsweise im bett liegt und die
wollte das handy lebens stellen wir
sehen könnt ihr das einfach so auf eure
nachttisch quasi stellen und das handy
hält dann quasi so von selbst und als
design gibt es einmal dieses hier also
in weiß mit einem schwarzen smiley das
ist für mich zum beispiel cool weil ich
eine weitwinkel und das handy habe und
es gibt auch noch das gleiche in schwarz
mit einem weißen smiley also für
schwarze handys quasi besser geeignet
dieses pop sockel wird 14 eur 99 kosten
ich hätte am liebsten für zwei euro 90
oder für 199 verkauft allerdings ist das
ein originales pop socken und die haben
darauf patent angemeldet und man muss es
so teuer machen bei dem einkaufspreis zu
teuer sind ich will hier nicht rum
prahlen oder irgendwelche falschen infos
verbreiten aber ich glaube ich mache am
wenigsten provisionen von allen youtube
anhin welche online shops haben weil
allein wenn ich euch das erste was bei
den neuen rudis und so an print drauf
ist es ein siebdruck drauf der kostet
mich so viel popsongs die kosten leider
14 eur 99 20 tage ich habe das teil
jetzt glaub ich seit 34 monaten drauf
oder sonst es immer noch perfekt aber
müsst ihr sein wissen ob es das wert ist
nicht ganz nur empfehlen also ist geil
ich würde zunächst zwingen aber wir
müssen ist leider so teuer machen
nominal ist das nächste produkt was ich
euch jetzt zeigen kann ich euch nicht
zeigen ja wie gesagt der druck ist die
farbe ist der kreis so was gab's noch
nicht so wirklich bei denen mit denen
ich meinen job mache und aber ich
erzähle ich etwas das hier ist das
produkt nämlich ein rudi mit der
aufschrift ilike pfizer man denkt erst
mal okay das ist jetzt nichts großes
oder so aber der druck beziehungsweise
der print auf dem rudi ist siebdruck das
heißt es wird zwar oft übereinander
gedruckt und das ist einfach man fühlt
den druck so richtig ich komme aus dem
bulli hat diesen pulli hatte ich schon
manchmal videos einmal ihr seht schon
hier ist auch so ein etwas anderer druck
weil so wenig ihn von der seite zeigen
seht ihr schon dass er fühlt sich denkt
der ist doch ein bisschen dicker mann
fühlt es richtig dass das am krasser
gummi druck siebdruck quasi drauf ist
und ihr werde das auch sehen wenn ihr
euch so ein highlight pizarro die
bestellt gefühlter darüber in mekka war
das ist so eine geile qualität alter
ralph lauren nichts kann man mit halb
und da fällt das problem wir wollen das
teil halt in so einem sandfarbenen ton
also ähnlich wie das hier noch so ein
bisschen heller und auch mit sonder
stift und an der siebdruck und hier oben
haben wir anstatt diesen plastikding
haben wir so metallteile dran und so war
es der polizei ein bisschen over size
sein also extrawünsche die ich hatte und
deswegen dauert das heißt so ein
bisschen alles aber ihr könnt auf jeden
fall jedes produkt am ersten zwölfter
schon bestellt ist kann nur sein dass
ein paar produkte direkt nach 23 tagen
an konnte beispielsweise der pop socke
sollte relativ schnell lieferbar seien
allerdings so was wie beispielsweise das
dauert vielleicht fünf sechs tage oder
so ist dann da ist ja extra schon
transporter nach italien geschickt er
produzierte italien hinter zünden
qualität westbad aber ihr könnt auf
jeden fall am ersten 12 und 16 uhr alles
bestellen
es hat da nur so ein bisschen lieferzeit
ein paar tage sag ich mal leute bleibt
unbedingt bis zum ende dran am ende
verkündete ich ein produkt was es so in
deutschland noch nie gegeben hat
aber gemach nicht weiter das nächste
produkt ist dieser zweite alles ist so
lief crack smileys wetter also der hut
sein enorm geilen straub so ein bisschen
dünner sage ich mal wenn ihr das kaufen
sollten wir doch schon das ist echt
qualitativ mega hochwertig und wir haben
extra vom druck ja so ein bisschen crack
drogen genommen weil den cola fanta als
gegen bison ganz normalen smiley druckt
will nicht zu weit aus dem fenster
lehnen aber dieses produkt ist mein
lieblingsfoto glaube ich in lucka shop
also den feierlich übel ins wasser mein
auge tut vw halte ein weiteres produkt
was am ersten zwölf neuen shop sein wird
ist einfach ein schwarzes t shirt nicht
dass hier das ist einfach nur ein zum
zeigen gerade
dass wir auch hier eine pizza
draufstehen haben also genauso wie auf
dem rudi auch unserem siebdruck und man
kann das wirklich fühlen dass da so eine
schrift rob ist und das sieht einfach so
geil aus ich kann das jetzt nicht zeigen
aber wenn irgendein auf euren freunden
sich sein publikum mit einer pizza bei
mir aus dem shop oder ihr selber er ohne
später drüber das ist ihr werdet nicht
mehr klarkommen dass die show wird aber
kein normales basic t shirt sein wird so
ein bisschen longhi mäßig sein das heißt
unten so ein bisschen länger ein
bisschen runder abgeschnitten und an den
ärmeln wird das ganze so aussehen
nämlich werden die ärmel so
zusammengenäht und das wird ab jetzt
wirklich bei allen t shirts und luca
shop so sein dass die ärmel
hochgekrempelt und zusammengenäht wert
bei mir selber es ist einfach so wenig t
shirts trage ich finde es so blöd wenn
die glatt runter laufen muss es immer
irgendwie hochkrempeln und findet sieht
irgendwie cooler aus deswegen hab ich
gesagt hey leute es halt noch mit meiner
neuen wohnung wir nehmen ab jetzt die
ärmel einfach so ein bisschen höheren
nehmen die halbfeld machen die t shirts
allgemein vom stoff her fester siebdruck
vorne bei dem ein spitzer schwarzen t
shirt und es ist meine landesbeste t
shirt des herrn lucas kommen wir nun zu
dem produkt auch dass er sie
viele gewartet habe und dass ich auch
schon so ein paar mal angeteasert habe
ins netz und video allerdings so
wirklich in deutschland glaube ich noch
keine youtuber wirklich umgesetzt hat
ich freue mich so dass es endlich
geklappt hat nach sieben monaten der
planung sei jetzt einfach mal die
komplette wahrheit über diesen prozess
mit der bettwäsche mit euch und zwar
produziert ja eigentlich überhaupt
mensch und vieh stehen halt für den
lukas shop und bereiten das alles vor
und wenn ich wünsche absagen es die nur
wir treffen und so geht das durch und
blablabla allerdings ist mein youtube
netzwerk studio 71 und die macher auch
merge mit ihm mache ich allerdings nicht
sondern halt nur holding esh weil das
irgendwie keine ahnung das hat sich
irgendwie so ergeben wird dann habe ich
halt gesagt ok bettwäsche mache ich mal
mit studio 71 und packte dann in den
luca schon weil ich bin ja ein 70 hat da
weißen nicht die hatten damals schon so
ein bisschen erfahrung und horny der
schotte vorher halt noch nie bettwäsche
gemacht lange rede kurzer sinn wir
hatten die ganze zeit studio 1 70 holy
milch und das waren so übel viele posten
und andererseits wollen wir die
bettwäsche schnell fertig kriegen
allerdings auf eine richtig gute
qualität und die bettwäsche hat eine
richtig gute qualität deswegen hat das
ganze ist einfach über sieben monate
hingezogen und wir haben dich nicht
wöchentlich telefoniert wegen dieser
bettwäsche deswegen kostet sie halt auch
glaube ich 60 euro die wird animiert
sein also ich glaube es gibt doch nur
500 stück
aber wir mussten den preis zu hoch
machen weil da so viele parteien run
verbunden waren die qualität muss hammer
sein es muss alles stimmen und endlich
an was fertig ich kann euch jetzt noch
kein bild von der bettwäsche einblenden
ich kann euch allerdings schon sagen wie
sie aussehen wird uns war wird sie so
weit so ein bisschen eierschalen weiß
normal weiß mäßig sache und dann so wie
das smiley europa schneller sie darüber
also kleine smileys drauf sind
ich weiß nicht wer jetzt über morgen am
ersten zwölf bis 16 uhr den joker chop
chop dort schon ein produktbild von der
bettwäsche sein wird allerdings könnte
sich schon vorbestellen da kommen sie
vielleicht noch vor weihnachten an aber
die hat also eine lieferzeit von zwei
bis drei bis vier wochen es tut uns
allen und vor allem wir und fassbar leid
dass das ganze erste so lange wieder
unter 20 teams und drittens immer noch
so lange lieferzeiten dabei wird das wir
haben damit komplettes neuland betreten
mit dem lukac ob die menschen mit
youtube in norddeutschland allgemeinen
und wir sind die ersten die bettwäsche
gelaunt an meine ich außer vielleicht
paar andere youtuber die das irgendwie
über china oder irgendeiner schnell shop
machen aber ich bin eher ein typ dafür
wie bei dem ich mehr geld aus und habe
länger was davon und wirklich was nicht
trennen was ich halt gerne habe anstatt
etwas was ich halt billig einkaufen und
ich meine spieler halt auch voll hinter
hinter meinen produkten und ich weiß
dass ich mich jeden tag darum wird
bemüht habe das ist irgendwie geil wird
und ich freue mich einfach dass es jetzt
klappt zum ersten zwölf ich verzichtet
auch gerne auf ein bisschen provisionen
aber es sind einfach keine produkt
sollte ich freue mich einfach auf den
lohn
das waren jetzt alle produkte die in der
luca shop kommen
das schwarze t shirt pizza den
sandfarbenen juni mit einer kita und
diese hunde jeder der die sind wie sind
bleibt die sind auch im neuen fahrer vom
über shop vertreten den blende ich euch
jetzt mal ein das ist nicht der neue
banner da sitze ich drei mal
nebeneinander photoshop skills wenn euch
das video gefallen hat meine damen und
herren das gerne mal mir tut es leid
dass jetzt in den letzten sieben tagen
glaube ich nur zwei oder drei videos kam
habe ich bin umgezogen gesät schon ich
befinde mich in einer neuen putze ich
bin so nah wie hier führt mich auf jeden
fall freuen wenn wir uns jetzt am ersten
12 und 16 uhr gesehen werden
also wenn ihr die seite einfach mal
besuchen würde die könnte ich die
produkte anschauen ich will dich nicht
zwingend etwas zu kaufen ist natürlich
jedem selbst überlassen aber schreibt
eure meinung in die kommentare
sobald er darauf gedacht ja ich will
jetzt keine produkt machen wohin
reißverschlusses und über alldem was
drauf gewartet sondern lieber passt wo
beispielsweise nur eine kita ganz klein
aber davon übels hochwertiger drucken
überzähliges t shirt das buch getrampelt
und so ein bisschen länger ihr seht
schon wo es hingeht imperativs
creativity und das bei einer möglichst
hohen qualität will gar nicht mehr lang
lagern ich habe euch alle lieb
die tage kommen jetzt öfter videos und
ich versuche wieder täglich aus
hochzuladen